تتسرب تصرفات مارجوري تايلور جرين
الغريبة وتتسبب في مشاكل هنا
على تلة الكابيتول ، ألق نظرة على هذا
الفيديو
الذي نشرته جرين اليوم على حسابها على
تويتر من يوم التصويت على الإقالة
[تصفيق]
المجرمين ،
نعم لا تصرخ على الناس توقفوا عن كونهم
منافقين
الآن كان ذلك غبارًا بين
عضوة الكونجرس الخضراء وعضوة الكونجرس الجدد كوري بوش من
ميسوري الذي حدث
في يوم التصويت على الإقالة
في الأنفاق بين مبنى الكابيتول
ومبنى مكتب المنزل الآن ،
تقول الأدغال أن الأخضر واجهها
واعتدى عليها لفظيًا
كثيرًا  طلبت تلك الشجيرة
نقل مكتبها بعيدًا
عن مكتب جرين في مبنى مكتب منزل لونغ وورث ،
وذهبت ونظرت إلى هذين المكتبين اليوم يمكنني
أن أؤكد أنه كانت هناك
صناديق متحركة أمام مكتب كوري بوش
الآن خضراء تدفع للخلف قائلة
أن الأدغال هي التي بدأت هذه المشاجرة
ولكن الذئب هو مجرد مؤشر
على كيف أصبح هذا مصدر إلهاء
كبير لكل العمل الذي يحتاج إلى  يتم ذلك
هنا على
تلة الكابيتول وكيفين مكارثي
يحاول زعيم الأقلية في المنزل معالجته
على الأقل على مستوى ما يخبرنا
أنه سيلتقي
مع مارجوري تايلور جرين هنا على
تلة الكابيتول في وقت ما الأسبوع المقبل